[Music]
so why did I choose this book I chose
this book because because I really liked
it a lot and I used to have a lot of
pressure choosing a book every month I
stopped doing that cuz it's really hard
you think about it yourself those of you
read it's really hard to find a book
that you love that you want to share
with all of your friends every month so
I just wait until I find something
that's fantastic and I want to pass it
along to everybody I know and everybody
I know in the world and that's what
happened I read this book it was sent to
me by the editor at O Magazine in a
stack and I picked it up and loved it
and wanted to pass it on that's how that
happened
[Music]
I think that resonates with me the most
is it's a love story that turns into a
triangle and I don't want to give it
away so we're one person in the triangle
ends up and what that outcome is so it
resonates because it's so current you
know I care a lot about what's happening
in the story and it's so current
[Music]
what struck me about the author is that
it was written as though it felt like I
knew the characters I thought that the
character development was so real that
the that the characters felt like real
people to me like I'd wake up thinking
about them that tell you you know you're
in a good book when you wake up thinking
about the characters and it's hard to
separate sometimes in your mind was that
real did that really happen no okay that
was in a book it was a novel that's how
good it is
[Music]